- Like the rules,
of modern society,
have led to,
everybody wants to blame
(upbeat techno music)
You've got your perspective.
I just want to be heard
♪ Try not to reason ♪
♪ You could just be yourself ♪
♪ Right now you're someone else ♪
♪ Right now I'm riding through the city ♪
♪ With my windows down ♪
♪ Something's in the air
I can feel that love ♪
♪ Someone bring me back to
life oh we all go down ♪
♪ Something's gotta change
I can feel that love ♪
♪ I be upset when I see the music ♪
- What advice, what could
we learn for those of us
on a more a traditional path,
from the non-traditional
folks that you work with.
- Um, you know, it's funny,
it's really hard to
(somber piano)
ask a giraffe to be a
penguin or vice versa.
And so, one thing that's
become much more obvious
to me as I've become older is like, wow,
DNA is powerful. Like,
I'm so comfortable with no
and losing, and fear,
but I'm so empathetic
to people that aren't.
I'm, and this will surprise a lot of you
that maybe follow me, I'm
unbelievably comfortable
with aggressiveness, and candor,
and binary talk on stage,
but one on one, I've really
struggled over the last 25
years as an executive with radical candor,
and shooting it straight
because I'm so optimistic
and I'm always trying to fix it.
And so, that's taken me a lot of work.
And through that work,
I'm like, okay, you know
there's the things that come naturally,
and things that aren't.
If you grew up in a framework
with parents, or customs
that really desperately over-value
outside affirmation,
the opinions of your
parents' parents, or siblings
because you come from a,
let's call it what it is
and immigrant background where there's
a huge commonality there.
Um, school. You were so
deeply bought into school that
the short term affirmation
of every 90 days with
grades and report cards
made you comfortable.
It's very hard to then go
into 'Hey, this is what
you should learn from entrepreneur land.'
Like, 'Don't worry about it,
it's all going to be fine!'
That's very hard. You've fully
built yourself as an animal
To completely value outside judgment,
that is not based on the market
but based on another human being.
That's what I'd like people
to learn, which is like
'Hey, like, what are we doing here?'
You've won the
four-hundred-trillion to one lottery
of being a human being,
do you really wanna live with regret?
Like, do you not understand
that the Internet is the
greatest optionality in
the history of mankind?
That are grandparents
and everyone behind them,
had nowhere close to the
options you sit with today?
And really, like what are
you valuing that's making
you conform into doing something
that doesn't make you happy.
Your current overhead? So
sell your home and rent.
That sounds crazy. You know
when I started about like,
hey, in the pursuit of
happiness, would you consider
selling your home, and renting,
I mean I got destroyed.
In the comments sections
and they love to play
like I'm some horrible person.
I mean like, how is living
your life to pay the bills
that you've created for yourself,
That's all humans, all
that humans do are create
their own jails and then live within it.
That's all we do! So, so,
knowing that that's very hard
in a human way, the situation
you have with your parents,
all that stuff, the
professional one feels like
I have a prayer of communicating
that, and here's my point,
if you wanna be a professional
skier, or if you wanna
start a blog or podcast around
cooking, my big thing is,
if you jump and start
swimming, you know this is why
riding a bike or kissing
a boy or girl, or, or, or,
you know, swimming, this
is, it seems super scary,
until you do it, and then you
just laugh about why it felt
so scary. Like if you go do that thing,
and live more humble,
live with judgment, you
could always get a job again.
Like, I dunno, like, I just,
my great fear is regret.
Because it is the obvious
thing I see in people that
are 80 to 100 years old
that seems super scary.
Nobody was thrilled that
they played it safe.
It just, you don't see it,
and I think people should
spend more time with 80 to
100 year olds that aren't
their grandparents. I mean it. I mean it.
I think people need context
on life a little bit.
I think people have a horrible
relationship with time.
Do you know how many people
in this room are scared
shitless of 30?
Like it's some thi- it means nothing!
But our society's decided
to tell you that you have to
figure it out. And marry and children,
and what are you talking
about? 98% of the 59 year olds
I know don't have it figured
out. The hell are we supposed
to have it all figured out at 30? 25?
Like, people are making
terrible decisions.
Getting married because they think
they're supposed to by this age.
You know, buying homes because
they think they're supposed to.
Like, the rules of modern society
have lead to-
Everybody wants to blame technology,
you know,
and drug companies, for
you know, all our problems.
We need to blame our norms.
Our expectations.
Our ridiculous north stars
that have, make no sense.
We're letting, when I look
at this young of a crowd,
they're living to 110.
There's an enormous amount of
people in here that are gonna
live to 110 that are
freaking out they don't
have it figured out by 30.
You're not even a fucking
quarter of the way there yet.
(somber piano)
- [Man In Suit] Can I
get your picture man?
- [Gary] You can bro.
- Aw, you're the man, thank you so much.
- You're welcome bro.
- Appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
(somber piano)
- [Unknown] Go, we, we
wanted to respond to your
request for our new video.
- [Gary] Great.
- [Unknown] So, um
- 'cause what, (murmurs)
What happens is, Jason and
Justin are coming to me
like 'Hey, when he, Gary calls
my name out in the crowd,
I want him to do something
right away to like help me-
- Sure 'cause fuck that, yeah
- Yeah, and like, we also
have a good system in play
for everyone that is working on stuff.
- So here's one thing.
This is the best analogy.
I don't even wanna have
this life if I can't do breaking news.
It's very nice that you have a news cast,
and that you had a nice
meeting this morning.
And we're gonna talk about
the earthquake in Africa,
and president Nixon's impeachment,
but if a tornado takes out the
entire state of Mississippi,
we report on that. I need to be that.
I'm breaking news. I don't
give a fuck about your system.
I want this fucking
video about me in a hat.
And we make that.
And then we're just one day
later on the next thing.
That's how it should be treated.
And I won't be mad at you,
like, I'll, I bet you guys
have been here not that
long, and already know
that I change my mind
on things all the time.
I need to taste.
(phone ringing)
- [Gary] Hey guys sorry
to interrupt your video,
I'm just giving you this
call from my number, uh,
to let you know that you have
to join my text community.
Uh, 212, 931, 5731, hit me up with a text.
- Does that make sense?
- [Man in Plaid Shirt] Yeah.
- Go ahead go ahead.
Let's get it out let's get it.
- It sounds like, uh I mean,
Like we go back and forth with this
We know the recent is something
we always wanna get into,
But it's also, we wanna make
sure this shit is tested
if it works on your pager.
- Here's the good news.
I don't ask often.
If I want the video of
this thing, let's do it.
Even though I just told
you if you don't test
I'm gonna die.
- Got it, so the ask is more of a one-off
than like , 'Hey, I'm thinking
the system shifts this way.'
- Gonna say it again. I'm breaking news,
you're the news cast.
- Yeah, makes sense.
- This what I don't, like,
my biggest thing is like,
like, I see it everywhere,
I don't ask that often.
So if I'm asking, like, we should do it.
There's, there's, I'm
not in the business of
disrupting for the sake of disrupting.
I'm a, I have a current
hypothesis that I need to
taste immediately.
- [Man In Plaid.] Well then uh, I wouldn't
worry about this then.
- Okay.
- [Man In Plaid] Because I
think we're just clarifying,
like, we were putting a
system in place where we gonna
get new clips out to you every
single day without you asking
just to make sure you have
new clips coming through
that are as tested as we can get them
in a two to three day period.
- [Gary] I want that. I want that.
- We can do that.
- And then I feel intuitively like
'Where the fuck are all the clips?'
Then I'm gonna be able to
say what I have to say.
Let me ask you a question,
when you're making notes
of like when we have
that great eye contact,
the fuck happens next?
- I bring it over here. And I'm at.
- (laughs)
- [Gary] On what kind of delay?
- Same night or day, next day.
- Next day, D Rock gives
you seven, two, four
moments in time.
- [Girl In Beanie] And
then he gives me, he
tells me which one's the best one,
and that goes
- [Gary] Yup!
straight into the cloud
where everyone, Airtable,
Where it's there.
- [Gary] And what happens next?
- All the platform owners then
choose from, from that day.
- [Gary] 'Kay.
- So if I log in on today,
then they look at today,
and they say
'Oh, this is a clip that
May logged from D Rock.'
- [Gary] If they don't
choose it, it could die.
- [May] Yes.
- Cool.
That's where we're broken.
Here's what I want from now on.
I want to hear the clips.
We need to put me at
the front, not the back.
It'll work, you'll see.
Good, that's where, that's the answer
to my question right now.
A month in.
Where's all my good shit?
Sitting in Airtable, not
picked, by Dustin, Danya,
or Caleb, or whoever the fuck is.
- [Man In Black Shirt]
Which is why I wanna put
that into Twitter and
into a raw platform not edited.
- [Gary] Love.
- And get it out.
- [Gary] Done. Approved.
Every clip gets put on Twitter.
I have to think about how I wanna do that,
but the answer is yes.
Like, whether it's Twitter
or post it raw somewhere,
we gotta think about where.
I gotta figure that out.
Yeah, no, it's not a
problem, we gotta fix it.
- [Man In Black Shirt]
And even, at a lot of
times we do put a lot on YouTube.
- [Gary] I still think that this is art,
and we're missing the biggest thing.
Like,
- [Caleb] The ideas?
- The ideas.
- We have me for creative
ideas. I'm really good.
I'm comfortable now saying that.
We need to use that as much as we can.
And when we can't, 'cause
I'm busy or on vacation,
You do the best you can.
- [Caleb] And then not take
'Hey where my cut has negative',
more as, 'Hey I just wanna
see something fresh',
but then also.
- [Gary] It's a negative.
Nothing's a negative. This is
a fucking game of perpetuity.
That being said, where
are the fucking clips.
(laughter)
Right? Like, like, I know
there's fu- I mean there's fire
from some days where I
haven't seen a single clip
I, I know this.
I know that there's a fucking
entire four day event.
- [Main In Black Shirt] Everyone does it,
we have it, that's the thing.
- So get it, figure out who's
the best on our team for
headlining and ID-ing the clips,
and then and the other
thing is me adding context
to quick ways is really good too.
Let's just figure it out.
Let's figure it the fuck out.
There's nothing else to say.
I need to be bothered.
- [Caleb] Smartly.
- And even not smartly. I'll
shoo you off if I'm busy
or upset.
You should never stop.
- Well we've done this
before of sending you a lot
of clips because I think
D Rock loves to just wanna
show you much we're pulling,
I think if we're saying,
ten, four, are actually
what we should have said
are our best concepts.
- [Gary] I just want the fire.
D rock's following me,
I'm a paying him to follow me
fucking around and not even
film to recognize of talents
being with me for a long time
so we can look at each other
of the five clips that matter.
It's that valuable, and I don't have 'em.
Figure that out.
- [Main In Plaid] That
we, that, we can fix.
- I believe so.
- [Main In Plaid] That's
our problem. We'll fix it.
- Yep, yeah, this is just
communication, this is good.
My energy right now is
more like excitement.
Than it is like, I'm pumped!
Let's just fucking fix it. To your point,
the fact that I haven't
even have them not gone,
like I have fucking two
years prior, is super fun.
But then there's been like
things where I give em the look
and I can't wait, and
now intuitively I'm like,
where is this?
I don't need to be the
person that's like who's the,
where's the African
American female, like, what?
I gave you the look, Jayce.
You made a note you took a screenshot.
- [Jayce] In the same way
though, 'cause it's like,
we send them out, or it's on-
- I believe you, I believe you.
No, it's very easy to
understand the system
Where, where, the potential
downbreak is like,
let's fix it.
We still don't have the
scaled solution of like where
are we gonna put it.
Twitter's the scariest
place to do it 'cause
mis-context destroys you.
- [Girl In Beanie] That's why
I think like, raw genie, like,
Team GaryVee on IG works,
'cause then you're getting
a raw version, and then
the well-produced version
is on Gary, so then you'll be like
oh let me go to see what's better.
- [Gary] You might be
diluting it on some of it,
that's okay too. Like,
listen, I'm not against it,
some days I have time to
look at it, and add context,
and other times, you got,
and by the way you guys
should be smart enough at
this point to know that I'm
worried about misinterpretation.
- [Man in Plaid Shirt] It
feels like there's just,
there's tiers, there's
your special request,
there's things you've already
flagged through D Rock
or the videographer of the day,
those are the things that
get elevated, escalated,
and done first, and then
there's ideation that happens
beyond those, but those are the
ones that we cannot mess up.
- That's for damn sure.
That's breaking news, but
more, but equally as important
is the fuck is he documenting?
We're always upside down
it's like everything else,
he should be making it on the spot,
which is why I don't want people.
I want one person to do the whole thing.
Jason, you got it, and you
got it, and you make it,
and you post it, and now,
that's why I always want
that system, because I
don't wanna hear this.
Jason you're filming,
you catch the six fire.
You make it all, I'll see
you in three days when you're
back from the cocoon, 'cause
you're going coast to coast
and I wanna fucking choke
your throat if it's,
who am I who to blame?
Right now I'm in this.
Cool. Awesome, thanks.
- [Girl In Beanie] Thank you.
- Want a coffee?
- Sure.
(laughter)
- Get outta here, now.
(techno music)
- [Gary] Yo, good day,
going to the Pencils of Promise Gala,
where I'm on the board,
which is why I'm suited up.
Which is rare.
Um, we should donate to
the Pencils of Promise,
That would make me happy.
Right there.
Good to go, it's a good day.
D Rock's lookin' at me.
Uh, and I'm telling Tyler that I think
Minnesota's gonna beat Penn State
So I'm putting it on the
record, Tyler doesn't think so.
Nor does most of the nation,
but, I'll stick with it.
See ya.
(somber piano)